[Music]
rami malek could take home his first
Oscar for his performance in Bohemian
Rhapsody in fact he is the only man up
for Best Actor who's nominated for the
very first time he was so good in this
movie one of my favorites of the year
and taking us all of course inside the
life of Freddie Mercury but how much do
you know about the life of Rami Malek to
get an Oscar nomination obviously the
highlight of my career
proves that we can achieve our dream
Rami was born on May 12th 1981 to
Egyptian immigrant parents he grew up in
LA and has an identical twin brother
named Sammy oh yeah that's what's been
happening ever since I was a kid so for
me to get into acting and get some
limelight back he's a teacher he's
extraordinary
Rami went to the same high school as
kirsten dunst and rachel bilson rachel
recently posted this amazing throwback
photo ET first met a 23 year old Rami on
the 2005 set of the Michael Rapaport
sitcom the war at home in 2016 Romney
won his first Emmy for his critically
acclaimed TV breakout performance in mr.
robot have you kind of taken a second to
pause and breathe in what just went down
no but his first Emmy red carpet was six
years earlier in 2010 let's just say
Rami had big dreams which left our guest
correspondent at the time Kate Gosselin
speechless
something that you'd see in my family
and then aspire to marry with and live
with for the rest of your life Rami is
now in a relationship with Bohemian
Rhapsody co-star Lucy Boynton and it's
safe to say he's a bit quirky he only
posts one Instagram photo a year why I
need more of you I think it's so fun he
also kept the prosthetic teeth that
helped transform him into Freddie
Mercury not only did I save that I cast
them in gold no you did not and that is
not something I would normally do but I
thought what is the most audacious
ostentatious thing that Freddie would do
and get this if Romney does take home
the gold this Sunday he will be the only
the fifth person to win both an Oscar
and an Emmy on their very first try the
other four of course Allison Janney
Patricia Arquette for swift Paris and
Halle Berry not bad company to be in